a second dawn to vladimir putin's war on
ukraine
devastation in the heart of the capital
kiev
ukrainian air defenses shot down a
russian jet overnight
air raid sirens continue to pierce the
sky
russian tanks are reported to be on
their way to the seat of power
putin decided to go for for clearly for
kiev so it's a behaving strategy that we
are watching here
and yes uh the russian forces are not
probably made as quickly progress as as
they expected pretty obvious that the
russian forces will prevail at some
point what putin wants to do is to to
impose the terms uh he wants probably to
have a regime that is seen as
sympathetic to to his
twisted vision of this greater russia
u.s defense secretary lloyd austin
warned russian forces are about 30
kilometers outside of the capitol
overnight the ukrainian president
addressed what russia has been saying is
its primary concern
today i've asked 27 european leaders
whether ukraine will be in nato i have
asked directly everyone is afraid no one
answers but we are not afraid we are not
afraid of anything we are not afraid to
defend our country we are not afraid of
russia we are not nato members at the
moment but what guarantees will we get
and most importantly which countries
will give us those guarantees
[Applause]
the kremlin has launched a multi-pronged
attack by air land and sea the military
is hitting major cities across the
country including kharkiv marapol and
nipro northeast of the capital in the
region of sumi an official provided a
grim update
unfortunately populated areas of sumi
region are under siege
military vehicles are moving towards
kiev and heading to the west
ukraine has banned all men between the
ages of 18 and 60 from leaving the
country
they're being told to stay and fight
many are desperate to leave after weeks
of threats people here simply didn't
believe it could happen
now on day two of the onslaught there
are fears that the arrival of russian
soldiers in the capitol is imminent
natasha ghanim al jazeera